you might think that you know everything
about your favorite Disney Princesses
but you'll be surprised to learn that
you could have been wrong after all or
maybe you are that person who keeps
telling everyone that no Elsa is not a
princess no matter what you'll want to
watch our video until the end to know
the truth about Moana if you love Disney
Princesses as much as we do don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
ten common misconceptions about Disney
Princesses Pocahontas did not fall in
love most of you know that the Disney
movie was based on a true story but what
you might not know is that the company
turned a tragedy into a fairy tale in
the movie Pocahontas met John Smith and
they both fell in love as they
discovered each others worlds she ended
up saving him but they finally had to be
separated if you watch the second movie
Pocahontas to journey to a new world you
also found out that the Native American
princess went to Europe and fell in love
with John Rolfe but this couldn't be
further from the truth
first Pocahontas was only a nickname
given to a girl named Matata meaning
spoiled child she was only a child when
she met John Smith so we really hope
that they did not love each other that
much actually according to the real poet
ination
she didn't like him at all she was taken
prisoner at age 17 and agreed to marry
John Rolfe as a condition of her release
Metallica became Rebecca Rolfe and had a
son named Thomas before passing away at
only 21 years old many people criticize
the Disney changed this terrible story
to make money and we couldn't agree more
with them if they wanted to tell
Pocahontas his story in a movie they
should have told the truth Snow White
was not old enough the Evil Queen wanted
to be the fairest of them all but when
she saw Snow White growing up and
becoming more beautiful every day she
decided to get rid of the competition
the Queen first asked the hunter to come
back with her heart but when she escaped
she saw that she would have to do it
herself by giving a poisoned Apple
to Snow White the young princess was
finally saved by a kiss of true love and
married the prince but this story is not
as beautiful as you might think
Snow White did not only marry a stranger
who kissed her when she was unconscious
but she was also too young to get
married
in the Disney movie Snow White was only
14 years old this is what makes her the
youngest Disney Princess but also the
oldest as she was the hero of the first
movie if you think that this is really
inappropriate wait until you hear about
the original tale in the fairy tale book
written by the Brothers Grimm the young
girl was only seven years old so it's a
good thing that Disney made her a little
older but this was still not enough 14
years old is too young to marry a prince
and live happily ever after
and no matter how old you are it is
always too soon to be chased by a hunter
who wants to steal your heart Elsa was
not a princess if you ask kids who was
their favorite Disney Princess in 2013
most of them would say that it was Elsa
too many people were singing let it go
and all the others had that song stuck
in their heads even if they didn't want
to she was the woman everyone wanted to
be Elsa was strong independent powerful
and she said one thing that everyone
will remember forever you can't marry a
man you just met we could say that she
was perfect after all but there is one
thing that Elsa can't be your favorite
Disney Princess that's because if you
watch the movie you would learn that she
is now a queen so yes she used to be a
princess just like her sister Anna when
their parents were still alive but
everyone saw that she was coronated as
the queen of arendelle in one of the
first scenes of the movie which gives
her an upgrade that we should not forget
it is great to finally see a powerful
woman in a Disney movie The Queen was
the hero of her own story she had to
deal with a lot of responsibilities and
she was mature enough to understand that
her sister was more important than any
man she'll ever meet but don't worry you
can still say that she's your favorite
Disney Queen Cinderella was not whee
now that we see women who are the heroes
of their own stories save their
countries and learn how to live happily
ever after without a man the first
Disney Princesses look a little weak
after all Cinderella didn't do anything
to make her life better when she was a
servant she received help from her fairy
godmother and her life suddenly changed
for the best when she met Prince
Charming she didn't even see memorable
for him and she had to try on a shoe to
prove that she was actually the love of
his life this might make little girls
feel like they just have to be pitiful
until a man comes by to save them but
you'd be wrong about that if any other
young woman were forced to work as a
servant her first reaction would
probably be to fight against her
stepmother and try to escape but
Cinderella was strong enough to control
herself and wait patiently instead of
making things worse anyone else would
have turned into a pitiful desperate and
angry character if they were treated
like that but there was nothing her
stepmother could do to keep her from
being beautiful nice and kind and unless
you are always able to stay calm in the
most terrible situations you cannot say
that Cinderella was weak Ariel was not
stupid the Little Mermaid was one of the
funniest characters we have ever seen
she was fascinated by the human world
and loved to collect objects that used
to belong to them then she asked her
friend scuttle to tell her what it was
and we were always surprised by one of
the most ridiculous answers this is why
when Ariel finally got a pair of legs
she wasn't shy to use her fork as a comb
in front of Prince Erik but don't think
that any of these mistakes makes her
stupid you would do weird things too if
you were suddenly turned into a mermaid
and tried to live amongst them Ariel was
actually one of the smartest Disney
princesses we ever met Ariel was
obsessed with one thing and she always
wanted to know more about it this is why
she kept collecting anything she could
find explore shipwrecks and asked many
questions and this is the best thing to
do if you ever want to become smarter
she just didn't have the chance to find
a good teacher until she met Prince Erik
but yes she did exchange her voice for a
pair of legs which was a little stupid
but she got what she wanted at the end
so we could say that Ariel was not only
but also very daring Mulan was based on
a legend many people think that Mulan
was based on a true story as we had the
chance to see in the Disney movie
a young woman knew that she wasn't meant
to be a housewife this is why she
decided to dress as a man and join the
army even if it meant breaking the law
it wasn't easy during the first days but
the young woman quickly learned to
become one of the best warriors by
working really hard and then Mulan ended
up saving her country and had nothing
left to hide
this story was realistic and this is why
many people thought that Mulan really
existed after all it wouldn't be the
first time that we see a woman
pretending to be a man to join the army
but unfortunately there is no proof that
Mulan ever existed the Disney movie was
actually based on the Chinese tale The
Ballad of Mulan in this story the young
woman was actually a very skilled
warrior and wasn't ashamed to tell her
family that she wanted to go to war
moreover no one really cared when she
revealed that she was a woman and she
was in the army for much longer than we
thought we'll probably never know if the
real Mulan ever existed so one thing is
sure for now the Disney movie could only
be based on the poem tiana didn't marry
a black man when the princess and the
frog was released we were all happy to
see an african-american woman get the
attention that she deserved tiana wasn't
waiting for a prince charming to save
her she knew that she had to work hard
to make her dreams come true but
everything changed when she turned into
a frog and the only thing she could
think about was becoming human again
even though people might say that we
watched her hopping around as a frog for
too long it was great to finally see a
beautiful and feminine black woman as a
role model
it was a big deal for all the little
girls of color who finally saw that they
could be a Disney princess too however
even though they were happy to see Tiana
some people were disappointed to see the
color of her prints when he turned back
into a human
naveen skin was brown but lighter than
Tiana's moreover his name is Indian and
he came from a kingdom that didn't exist
a Disney executive even said that his
background was made up so he was
whatever ethnicity they
have in fictional maldonia but no matter
what his color was we think that
everyone should be happy to see the two
lovers together it was great to see
people of different ethnic backgrounds
falling in love with each other
Belle didn't need a man in the first
Disney movies we were used to seeing a
poor princess who was waiting for Prince
Charming to come and save her simply
because she was kind and beautiful it
made us think that women couldn't be the
heroes of their own stories and that
their role was just to look good and
wait patiently but Belle was not a young
woman like any other yes she did fall in
love with a prince but this time he was
not the one who saved her she was the
one who saved him the bookworm was
already happy to live with the most
important man in her life her father a
man was interested in her but she
couldn't care less Belle knew that she
deserved better than marrying a man who
had nothing more than good looks meeting
the Beast was more a tragedy than love
at first sight but she decided to make
the best out of this situation
she wasn't saved by her good looks but
because she knew that the best thing to
do was to give him the chance to become
a better man there is nothing wrong with
falling in love as long as you know that
you are more than someone's wife if the
Beast had never been there
Belle would have been happily ever after
anyway Aurora was not boring Sleeping
Beauty was the kind of girl who couldn't
do anything but wait patiently for her
prince charming to come and save her
with a kiss of true love out of all the
other Disney princesses Aurora had the
least screen time 18 minutes to be exact
during this time she only spoke eighteen
times that was not a lot if she wanted
to be the hero of her own story actually
the three fairies were better
protagonists than her but that didn't
mean that the girl didn't make the best
out of that short time and she was
certainly not boring Aurora was
described as gentle and loving but we
could also say that she was obedient
dreamy romantic and loyal and we know
that she must have something really
special to make the Prince fall in love
at first sight this kind of fairy tale
story doesn't happen every day and no
matter what Aurora stood up for herself
when she said that she didn't want to
marry a random Prince she wanted to
marry for love she might have been
sleeping for a long time in the movie
but we can't say that it was her fault
don't forget that she had been cursed
and we also have to admit that we would
like to be just like her sleeping as
much as we want until the love of our
lives comes to save us is a dream come
true
Moana was not a princess if you think
that Moana is your favorite Disney
Princess we are sorry to tell you that
you are wrong we love that she is
independent strong and daring she had
the courage to break the rules and face
everyone's fear to save her tribe and on
her way to accomplish her mission she
found something that was even more
important who she truly was Moana was an
amazing woman but there is one thing she
was not she was not a princess if you
don't believe us remember that she said
it herself in the movie when Moana
decided to set out on a canoe against
the wishes of her father she met the
demigod Maui he made the mistake to
repeatedly call her princess but Moana
clarified that she was not a princess
she was the daughter of the chief to
this Maui replied that if you wear a
dress and have an animal sidekick you're
a princess we have to admit that it made
us laugh but no matter what we'll have
to believe our favorite character and
admit that she was not a princess after
all and she will probably never be did
we forget any other common misconception
don't be shy to tell us what it is in
the comments section down below we love
to know what you think and that's it for
10 common misconceptions about Disney
Princesses for more stories like this
make sure you watch 10 deleted Disney
Princesses and rejected concepts thanks
for watching
[Music]